PROFESSOR: OK, here we go.
Couple of things.
Sorry, I forgot to bring candy,
but it'll be on sale next week.
So we can probably
bring it next week.
But walking over, I thought,
boy, those of you who are here
deserve some candy.
But I've just tried to sprinkle
in a few interesting slides
for your benefit.
I saw this on the
MIT news of the day,
and I thought that
was really cool.
Who would have thought to turn
the giant dome into a Halloween
pumpkin?
And I was also
jealous this morning
when my husband got ready to
go work in the emergency room
and he put on his
Star Trek outfit.
So I was like, oh,
I didn't even have
a-- because I don't
usually get to actually
have a class on the
day of Halloween.
So he headed off.
I think people are
unfortunately going
to expect him to be able to
really fix things very readily
in the emergency room
today because he's
going to have all those extra
powers that he doesn't usually
have.
But anyway, so
actually it's kind
of a good day for a
lecture, Halloween,
because we're going to talk
about the fight or flight
response, which is
a great paradigm
for cellular signaling.
So you're going to see
how signaling really
works in action.
Because what one
has to think about
with respect to
cellular signaling
is that it's dynamic
and transient.
And when we look at
the molecular details
of the switches that enable
dynamics and transient behavior
in cells, you're going to
see how perfectly adapted
they are for these
types of responses that
have to be carried out
in cells or in organs
in order to respond to a
particular signal rapidly
and with a definitive
time frame and then
have that signal then stop
once the time frame has passed.
So I really want to
sort of stress to you
the characteristics of
signaling that can emerge just
by knowing about two
particular cellular switches,
knowing the molecular
details of those switches,
to really understand, then,
when we look at them in action
in a couple of cellular
signaling pathways,
then we'll see how
adapted those signals are.
And the great
thing about biology
is that once you learn a
few very specific things,
then those often get
reused in nature.
So the cellular signals that
I'm going to describe to you
are used again and again
in different formats
to create different
signaling pathways.
So it's not at every pathway.
And every cell in the body
has different nuances.
It has general paradigms that we
can learn about and understand,
all right?
So the key feature is then to
think about the molecular basis
of these switches.
So last time, I was talking to
you about cellular signaling.
And remember, there's
always a signal, a response,
and an output.
So something happens.
It's a signal.
It's usually a molecule of
some kind outside the cell
or able to diffuse
into the cell.
As a function of that
signal, there's a response.
So this is molecular.
The response obviously
is biochemical.
And the output is biological.
So I want you to sort
of think about these
as we look at pathways.
What's really my
output at the end
of a particular
signaling pathway?
What was my input?
How did it get to the cell?
How does it have a dramatic
effect on the cell as a whole?
How does the timing and
action of this effect
occur so rapidly?
So we talked last time
about different types
of signals, those
that mostly occur
in the cytoplasm of the
cell with signals that
are able to diffuse across
the plasma membrane and bind
to an intracellular receptor
and then cause an action.
But really, the most
important ones for today
are going to be the
types of receptors
that span the membrane.
And the reason why these
are much more significant,
they're more in number,
they're more predominant,
is if you have a membrane
spanning receptor,
you have the opportunity
to use signals
of very, very different types.
Small polar molecules, small
proteins, lipids, amino acids,
carbohydrates.
You've got a much
larger range of signals
than you could possibly have
if you restricted yourselves
to the type of signals that
can cross the cell membrane.
Those are very limited to
non-polar small molecules that
can get across the membrane.
The more dominant
types of signals
are going to be the ones
that are outside the cell.
They arrive at a cell surface.
They bind to a receptor that
is transmembrane and transduce
a signal from the
outside to the inside.
So that's an
important term here,
the process of transducing
external information
to internal information.
So when we started
the course, we
were really thinking
about laying down
the cellular membrane as
an encased environment
where things could occur
at high concentrations.
You could set up
systems that were
functional within membranes.
But in doing that within
a membrane encased area,
in doing that, you've
built a formidable barrier
around the cell.
So the types of receptors
that we'll talk about
are those that have adapted to
take this external information
into the cell and then have
a cellular consequence occur.
So I'm going to talk to you
about two specific types
of cellular
switches, and they're
going to be intracellular.
And we're going to be referring
back to these because they're
going to be important as we
dissect a signaling pathway.
So the first type-- so
stand aside a moment.
Put aside a moment
the actual process
of a signal binding
the response,
both biochemical and biological.
Let's look first at
the molecular detail
of these switches
and see how they
are adapted to their function.
And the first type
of cellular switch
are what are known
as G proteins.
The G is because they bind
guanidine nucleotides.
So that's why they're
called G proteins.
They're small proteins
that bind GDP or GTP.
So this is the
guanine nucleotide
that has either two phosphates,
guanidine diphosphate
or triphosphate.
So there may or may not
be a third phosphate here.
And the G proteins bind them.
And the dynamics
of the situation
are that when the G
proteins are bound to GDP,
they are inactive.
The switch is off.
There's an aspect
of the structure,
and it's very dependent on
how many phosphates there
are in this structure.
But it's when it's bound
to the diphosphate variant
of the nucleotide, then
it's an off switch.
And when it's bound to GTP, it's
an on switch and it's active.
So this is the molecular
basis of one of the switches.
It relies on the shape,
the conformational dynamics
of these small G proteins.
And that shape is
quite different
if it's bound to guanidine
diphosphate or triphosphate.
And we'll take a
look in a moment
at how the structure,
the shape, changes.
The shape shifts upon binding
the triphosphate analog.
So this is a dynamic
interconversion.
When the GTP is
hydrolyzed, you go back
to the GDP-bound
state, the off state.
And there are a
variety of proteins
that actually help these
processes, which we
won't talk about in any detail.
The main thing that
you want to remember
is that when the G
proteins are bound to GTP,
they're in a non-state.
GDP, they're in an off state.
And that's shown
in this cartoon.
And here I should be able to,
if all goes according to plan,
show you the structure of a GTP
analog bound to a G protein.
So lets-- this little
guy is twirling around.
He's settled down a little bit.
The key thing you
want to look at
is where it's magenta
and cyan, the structure
of the GDP and GTP-bound G
protein are very, very similar.
But big changes
happen in the yellow,
which is the GDP-bound
form, and the red,
which is the GT-bound form.
Let me go back again so you
can see that one more time.
So in the GTP-bound form,
a portion of the protein
swings around and binds to
that third phosphate on the GTP
and forms a different
shape to the structure.
And that's a dynamic
change that's
responsible for activation.
When it's just GDP,
that's shorter.
There's nothing for
that red arm to bind.
And so it's much more
of a floppy structure.
What I want you to notice in
that little yellow portion
in the GDP-bound
form, you actually
don't really see where the
rest of the protein is.
This is because this
is a crystal structure.
And in the crystal structure,
when things are very mobile,
you can't even see
electron density.
It's as if the
part of the protein
isn't there because
it is so dynamic.
It's only in the
GTP-bound form it
forms this tight,
compact structure
that represents a switch
that has been turned on.
Does that make
sense to everybody?
Is everyone good with that?
So just that change, that extra
phosphate reaching further
to the protein and
making an interaction
with the protein itself,
makes the difference
in the dynamics of the G
protein and the activity here.
Now, there are different
types of G proteins.
And you'll see both types
reflected in this lecture.
There are small G proteins,
and they are monomeric.
And then there are slightly
more complicated G proteins
that are trimeric.
They have a
heterotrimeric, structure.
So they have
quaternary structure
where you have three
different proteins
as part of the complex.
So the other ones are trimeric.
And the G protein actually
comprises three subunits
where one of them is
the important one that
binds GDP or GTP.
But they are a little
bit more complicated.
And in the first
example when I talk
about a particular
response to adrenaline,
we're going to see the
trimeric G proteins.
And because they're
trimeric, that
means there's three subunits.
And the convention is that they
get the Greek lettering system.
So they are the alpha,
beta, and gamma subunits.
They've each got their name.
They're three independent
polypeptide chains.
And it's actually the alpha
subunit that binds GDP or GTP.
So that's the formulation of
one of the types of switches
that we're going to see when
we start to look at a pathway.
What do you need
to remember here,
you need to focus on the
fact that in one state,
the protein is in an off state.
It doesn't kick off
a signaling pathway.
But in the other
state, the protein
is a different shape
because of binding a loop--
let's just make this
a little longer--
to that phosphate
that's negatively
charged to the protein.
So that's an on state.
And they are very definitive
types of structures.
Now, both of these
proteins are intracellular,
which means they're part of the
response once a signal reaches
a cell.
They are things that change.
And they're what the signal gets
transduced to, the G proteins.
Now, there's another type
of intracellular switch
which is used very, very
frequently in nature.
And in fact, it
crosses, permeates,
through all kinds of
cellular processes.
And this is phosphorylation.
So here are the G
proteins, which is one.
And the other one
is phosphorylation.
I don't like that chalk.
OK, now remember, we
talked about reactions
of proteins that
alter their behavior,
their properties,
their dynamics.
So protein
phosphorylation, remember,
is a post-translational
modification, a PTM.
It's something that
happens to a protein
after it has been
translated and folded.
And the PTMs in
a phosphorylation
involve amino acids
that have OH groups.
So that's the
structure of tyrosine
where the squiggles represent
the rest of the protein.
And on phosphorylation, we
append a phosphate group--
whoops, a minus, a minus--
to the oxygen on tyrosine
on the side chain.
So actually, it looks
pretty different.
It behaves pretty differently.
There are two other
residues in eukaryotic cells
that are commonly
phosphorylated.
There are the other two
that include OH groups.
So they are serine
and the third one--
as I run out of space, but
you get the general message--
and threonine.
So these are the three
amino acids that commonly
get a phosphate group attached.
And they change
their properties.
They are called kinases.
Kinase, the root of the word
is actually "to change."
So the enzymes that
catalyze this change
are known as kinases.
And in contrast to the
G proteins that use GTP,
the kinases most commonly use
ATP to give up a phosphate
to phosphorylate the protein.
So there's another substrate
in this reaction is ATP.
Now, when we look
at this structure,
there's two or three
things I really
want to call your attention to.
If we're dealing with
this kind of switch,
we can go back to the off
state by chopping up the GTP
and making it GDP again.
So that's how to turn
the light back off.
In the case of
the kinases, we've
got to do something to
go back from this state
to the non-modified state to
turn the light switch off.
So for every transformation in
the cell that involves kinase,
there is a corresponding
set of enzymes
that reverse the reaction
called a phosphatase.
It takes that group off again.
So let me write that down here.
Now, phosphate is used a lot.
So this is a
phosphoprotein phosphatase.
So kinase puts the phosphate on.
The phosphoprotein phosphatase
takes the phosphate off.
There are three
types of amino acids
that get most commonly
modified in our cells--
tyrosine, serine, and threonine.
And one of the ones that
forms an important part
of an extracellular
signaling mechanism
are the tyrosine kinases.
And we'll delve into them in a
little bit, not the section I'm
going to cover now, but later.
Because tyrosine,
various kinases
come in a lot of
different flavors.
The common flavors
are whether you
modify tyrosine or
threonine/serine,
because these are more
similar to each other,
and this guy is different.
But we'll get to that later.
So in the cell, we
have about 20,000 genes
that encode proteins,
encoding genes.
All right, 515 of
those are kinases.
That's a pretty big chunk of
the genome you've got to accept.
So in excess of 500 kinases.
Specifically, protein
kinases, the ones that modify.
So there's a big hunk
of the genome dedicated
to this kind of activity.
And there's a dynamic
because there's also
about 100 phosphatases.
They are a little
bit more promiscuous.
You don't need so many of them.
But a large sort of
component of the genome
is responsible for
phosphorylating proteins
and dephosphorylating
phosphoproteins.
And that part of the genome
has its own special name.
And it is called the kinome.
I hope that's not
too small in there.
So if we're describing
all the enzymes
in the genome that
catalyze phosphorylation,
we would call it the
kinome as a collective set.
Because it's the set of kinases.
And you'll hear that
term quite commonly.
And the kinome is
really important
and represents major,
major therapeutic targets.
Because it's when
kinases go wrong
that we have
physiological defects.
So let's just go back to this.
You can see we've got the
kinase and the phosphatase.
The donor for
phosphorylation is ATP.
And it is the gamma
phosphate that's
transferred to the protein to
switch it from the off state
to the on state.
It is a post-translational
modification,
meaning it occurs on a
protein after the protein has
been fully translated.
There are a few
cotranslational PTMs.
That seems like a
bit of an oxymoron,
cotranslational modifications.
But phosphorylation
isn't one of them.
Glycosylation is.
And we won't go into
those in any detail
even though it breaks my
heart not to go into those.
But OK, all right, so now I want
to first of all introduce you
to a paradigm for signaling
as opposed to really go
into what's happening.
And so one of the
first paradigms
is a situation where
you have a cell.
In the plasma membrane of
that cell is a receptor.
And it gets hit with a signal.
So a signaling paradigm
is that a molecule
from outside the cell binds to
something that's transmembrane.
And then you start getting
signal transduction
through a pathway.
So any extracellular signal
could be game in this process.
And then there's a
sequence of events.
Upon signal binding,
there's a sequence
of changes that ends you
up with a final output.
And generally,
signaling pathways
go through a number
of steps where
there is the opportunity for
the amplification of a signal.
So I talked to you
last about time
about some of the
hallmarks of signaling.
Specificity defines how
accurately that extracellular
signal binds to the receptor.
But amplification
really refers to how
signals get bigger and
bigger through certain steps
in a signaling pathway
in order to have
a big impact in the cell,
not just a single event going
through a single pathway
one molecule at a time.
And we'll see that in the
example that I show you.
And then oftentimes when we
look at signaling pathways,
we care a great
deal about what's
the first response
upon the signal hitting
the outside of the cell.
So in many signaling pathways,
this could be a protein.
The receptor could be a protein
that is bound to a G protein.
And that would be
the first responder
through the pathway
that really triggers off
the cellular events.
OK, and now, so what I want
to talk about now, is the--
I always get this wrong.
I always thought it was flight
or fight or fight or whatever,
fright.
I always thought it was flight
or fright, but it's not.
The response is actually
the fight or flight.
So let's set this
up to understand
why this is such a
great manifestation
of a cellular
signaling response.
Because it includes a
lot of the hallmarks
that are really characteristic
of the cellular response.
So this response involves
a cellular receptor
that is called a G
protein coupled receptor.
We saw a little bit
about them last time.
They are always called
GPCRs for short.
And what that term
means is that it's
a receptor that is linked
in some way to a G protein.
So it could be coupled to
a monomeric or a trimeric G
protein.
So don't confuse the two.
One is the receptor.
It's transmembrane.
It's responsible for receiving
signals and transducing them.
The first responder
is the G protein
that changes from a GDP-bound
stage to a GTP-bound state.
And in the one that we're
going to talk about,
we're going to deal with a
trimeric G protein in the fight
or flight response.
And what you see
here is a cartoon
of the players
that are involved.
So remember the G proteins?
We talked about them
briefly last time.
They have seven
transmembrane helices.
They span the membrane.
They have the N
terminal outside.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
N terminus out, C terminus in.
And each of these is
a transmembrane helix.
And this would be
outside the cell.
This would be in the cytoplasm.
OK, and you can
actually often look
at the transmembrane protein
and know its behavior.
Because the width of
these transmembrane
helices often comes in at
approximately 40 angstrom,
which is the span of a membrane.
You can sort of say, that looks
like a transmembrane helix
because it's exactly that
dimension to cross a membrane.
And the GPCRs in
this case would bind
to a ligand outside
the cell and have
a response inside the cell.
So those seven
transmembrane helices
are responding to
ligand binding.
So let's take a
look at this picture
because it's almost
impossible for me
to get it onto the screen.
So it binds to a
trimeric G protein.
Remember, I talked to you
about the two different types.
The trimeric has an alpha, beta,
and gamma subunit quaternary
structure.
And they're shown here
in different colors.
The green is the alpha subunit.
The red is the gamma subunit.
And the yellow is
the beta subunit.
So what happens, when the ligand
binds the G protein coupled
receptor, there is a
reorganization of those seven
transmembrane helices.
Last time, I
identified them to you.
When you look at
a couple of these,
they're actually
fairly large loops
that grab onto your ligand.
And then that will translate
conformational information
through the membrane
to the other side
where the G proteins
are sitting.
And in this response,
what happens
is upon binding the ligand, the
alpha subunit leaves the team
and goes from their GDP-bound
state to the GT-bound state.
So it literally
changes its state
and changes its
mode of association
within the cell
upon that action.
So you can see how
nicely we have transduced
the ligand binding out here to a
pretty discrete cellular event,
turning on the switch of
the G protein alpha subunit.
Is everyone following me there?
I know it sort of looks
complicated to start with.
But you'll see it in action.
OK, so here are the cellular
components of the response.
So basically, this is
the kind of response
where if you get scared or
you feel you're in harm's way,
you will trigger this
response in order
to generate a lot of ATP in
order that you can respond--
run away, hide, do
something very active
in order to rapidly respond
to a threat of some kind.
And this response is
triggered by a small molecule.
In this case, it's
epinephrine or adrenaline.
Different names on different
sides of the Atlantic,
but you all know
what adrenaline is.
And here's the structure of
epinephrine or adrenaline.
And it is the signal for
the flight or fight response
because it's the small molecule
that binds to the extracellular
surface of the receptor,
changes its shape
so that things can
happen intracellularly.
And it's just one
small molecule.
Normally that would be charged.
It doesn't diffuse
across the membrane.
So it's stuck being on the
outside of the membrane, OK?
So this is the signal that
triggers the response.
So if you have to respond
to a threat of some,
kind you can't stop, sort of go
to the fridge, get a big snack,
eat it, digest all your
food, and hope you're
going to get energy quickly.
What you've got to
do is have a response
where you can generate energy
from your glycogen stores that
are in the liver.
So there is a signal comes
from the adrenal region, which
is the release of adrenaline
that goes to the cell surface
receptors to trigger
the response.
And what kind of
signal would this be?
Would it be paracrine,
autocrine, exocrine?
What kind of signal
would that be?
Sorry-- endocrine,
paracrine, juxtacrine
Do you remember last time?
Yeah--
AUDIENCE: Endocrine.
PROFESSOR: Endocrine,
so it's a response that
comes from the kidneys
and goes to the liver.
So it's going, it's traveling.
Autocrine is self.
Paracrine is near.
Juxtacrine is cell contact.
But any of these
hormonal responses
are pretty commonly
endocrine responses.
So what happens once
the signal binds?
So the specificity in this
situation is that the G protein
coupled receptor-- now shown
in pink in very stylized form,
but you can count those
seven transmembrane domains--
will bind exclusively to this
GPCR with high specificity.
Another signal,
another small molecule
that looks like it won't
bind because we have to have
specificity for the signal.
Upon that binding event,
it will trigger a change
within the cell.
And that change within the cell
is that the alpha subunit--
here you see alpha
subunit, beta, gamma.
They're all shown in green.
The alpha subunit
of the G protein,
remember, I told you
it was a trimeric G
protein where the alpha
subunit is the key player.
The alpha subunit leaves the
team and it exchanges its GDP--
that's its resting
state, nothing's
happening-- for GTP,
which turns it on.
So that's the first response.
The G protein is
responding to the signal
from the outside of the
cell through the auspices
of the G protein
coupled receptor
to give a change within the
cell that's a discrete change.
OK, following me so far?
So now what we need to do
is trigger the remaining
biochemical events that
are going to get us out
of this sticky
situation where we
need to produce a lot of ATP.
So it turns out that
the GTP-bound form
of the alpha subunit can
then bind to another enzyme.
And that enzyme is
adenylate cyclase.
So we've bound, we've
changed the GDP to GTP,
there's a response,
and we activate
the enzyme known as AC,
which you look up here,
it's called adenylate cyclase.
So this is a messenger
within the cell that's
now being generated
as a response
to the signal coming from
outside through the GPCR
to the alpha subunit
of the G protein,
which, then, in its GTP-bound
state, binds adenylate cyclase.
OK, is everyone with me?
And once that is bound,
adenylate cyclase
can do its biochemistry.
And the biochemistry that
adenylate cyclase does
is shown down here.
Here's ATP.
Adenylate cyclase cyclizes ATP.
You lose two of the
phosphates, and you
get this molecule known
as cyclic AMP, which
is a messenger molecule that
will propagate information
through the cell.
So now, the adenylate
cyclase is activated
because it's bound
to the GTP-bound form
of the alpha subunit.
That means we can make
a bunch of cyclic AMP.
And cyclic AMP is what's
known as a second messenger.
And that often means
it's a common messenger
in a lot of pathways.
It shows up quite frequently
within the wiring of a pathway.
And it acts locally to where
the pathway is being processed.
So once cyclic AMP is
formed by adenylate cyclase,
that then activates an enzyme.
It activates protein kinase
A. So PKA is a kinase.
It's actually a serine
threonine kinase.
And that then results
in certain proteins
within the cell becoming
phosphorylated to continue
propagating our effect.
So we have specificity by
the adrenaline binding.
We have amplification
somewhere in this pathway.
So I told you that many pathways
go through steps where you
start amplifying the signal.
Where do you think
is the first stage
in this set of
transformations that I've
described to you where you start
amplifying the information?
Think about what each
of the events comprises.
Is this one binding
to one in one event,
or is it one binding to one
and we get multiple events?
Where is the first step of
amplification that's essential?
Because it wouldn't
do us any good
if we make one molecule of
ATP at the end of the day.
We've got to make dozens and
dozens of molecules of ATP.
What's the first event that
could be an amplification?
Over there--
AUDIENCE: Is it when [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
when it's made, yes.
So this, let's go through them.
One binds to one, great.
Once one binds to one,
one of these is released.
It gets converted
to one of these.
Once one of these is made,
adenylate cyclase is an enzyme,
so it can make a
bunch of cyclic AMP,
which can then activate
a bunch of protein kinase
A, which can then phosphorylate
a bunch of cellular proteins.
So we've got an expansion
of our response.
All right, so everyone, does
that make sense to everyone?
So amplification is
really important.
Feedback is also important.
If you ended up needing
an EpiPen because you
have an allergic
response, you might
remember that you've
got the jitters forever
because there's too much
firing and action going on.
But in the fight
or flight response,
there's feedback at
a certain stage that
slows down this entire process.
And that feedback actually
comes from an enzyme
that chomps up the
cyclic AMP to make it
inactive as a second messenger.
So there's feedback
in this process.
OK, now, what happens
within the cell
to get us that
biological response?
This is a sort of a shortened
version of what's happening.
So epinephrine binds.
Here we are with the alpha
subunit with cyclic AMP.
For each one of
these, you might make
20 molecules of cyclic AMP.
That would inactivate
many, many PKAs.
And then you go through a
series of biochemical steps
where different
enzymes are activated
with the overall goal of in the
liver chewing up glycogen. OK,
so glycogen is a pretty
impenetrable polymer
of carbohydrates.
And you need several enzymes
to start to break glycogen down
to make glucose phosphate.
And so these enzymes here
of phosphorylase, B kinase,
glycogen phosphorylase all
end up converting glycogen
into glucose 1 phosphate.
So you access your liver stores
of stored carbohydrate, which
is in a polymeric form, to get a
lot of glucose phosphate, which
is then hydrolyzed to glucose,
which then hits the blood
system.
And then you can deliver
glucose to all the cells
to go glycolysis and make ATP.
And every glucose
molecule, as you know,
can really churn out ATP.
So what we see in
this process is
going through the entire
dynamics of the system
where we've seen specificity,
amplification, and feedback.
Later on, I'll describe
integration to you.
OK, everyone following?
The series of steps that go
from a molecular messenger
to biochemical steps to
physiological, biological
response.
Now, I want to just emphasize
one quick thing here.
I've got a couple of slides
I popped in of drug targets.
About 45% are
receptors in cells.
25% of the entire drug
targets are GPCRs.
They respond to all
kinds of signals--
amines, amino acids, lipids,
little peptides, proteins,
nucleotides--
all commonly going
through the G protein
coupled receptor to give you a
similar phenomenon to what I've
described to you.
And what I think is
particularly interesting--
I'm going to post all
of these as slides.
What I want you to see,
this was quite a while
back, but it just shows you so
many of trademarked drugs that
target different GPCRs--
they're shown here-- and
what diseases they're
used for to treat, and
what's the generic name
of those drugs.
So you can see here
many, many diseases
have at the heart and
soul of their problem
different receptors.
And these are all G
protein coupled receptors
that are treated
with small molecules
that bind to the receptor
and often glue it
in an inactive state
so it can't, then,
bind to an activating signal and
have all the rest of the events
occur.
There are very few
structures of the G protein
coupled receptors, but
there are some of them.
So many of the target G
protein coupled receptors
can be modeled computationally.
And then you can
do a lot of work
where you actually
model the receptor
in a membrane
environment and start
searching for drugs through
computational approaches.
And I thought a lot of you
might be interested in this.
Because this is a
really strong axis
where bioinformatics,
confirmation,
and advanced physics
and molecular dynamics
can be brought to
bear on drug discovery
when you don't have
perfect molecular models
of your targets.
OK, so now we're going to move
to a different kind of signal.
We're going to talk about the
receptor tyrosine kinases.
All right, so in the receptor
tyrosine kinase responses,
we can often see very
similar paradigms
to what I've just shown you.
But there is an
important distinction.
Receptor tyrosine kinases,
we often call these RTKs.
So that's their shorthand.
So over here, I described
to you different kinases.
That we have kinases that
modify threonine, serine,
and tyrosine.
The receptor tyrosine kinase
is a subset of tyrosine kinases
that form part of a receptor.
So if you were to think
about various kinases,
you would have the
serine/threonine,
and you would have
the tyrosine ones.
But these would
be differentiated
into the ones that are part of
a membrane protein, the RTKs,
and then the ones that are
soluble in the cytoplasm.
And the serine/threonine
ones are most commonly
soluble in the cytoplasm.
I'm going to focus on the
receptor tyrosine kinases
because they do slightly
different activities when they
signal relative to the GPCRs.
So that's once again,
this is a situation,
another paradigm where you
see a series of events.
But with a number of
the receptor tyrosine
kinase pathways,
the ultimate action
ends up being in
the nucleus where,
as a result of an
extracellular signal,
you get a series of events that
ends up with a protein being
sent into the nucleus.
And that protein may be a
transcription factor that
binds to a promoter region.
And as a result of that, you'll
get gene transcription occur.
You'll transcribe a
gene, make a messenger
RNA that will leave the
nucleus and cause action
within the cell.
So this is a little
bit different
than the other response
that was mainly cytoplasmic.
OK, so let's take a look at
the receptor tyrosine kinases.
Receptor tyrosine
kinases are proteins
that span the membrane
but rather differently
from the GPCRs.
And they have a domain
that's extracellular, just
a single transmembrane domain.
So this is out.
This is in.
And then they have an
intracellular domain.
This would be where
the ligand binds.
This would be how there's some
kind of signal transducing.
And this would be
a kinase domain.
OK, so how do we get
the information in?
When we saw the GPCRs, we saw
the ability of those seven TMs
to kind of reorganize and
send information in the cell.
With the receptor
tyrosine kinases,
it's kind of different.
There are regions of
the membrane where there
are a lot of these proteins.
They commonly bind small
peptides and protein molecules.
And when they're in
their activated form,
once the small protein binds,
the receptor tyrosine kinase
forms a dimeric structure.
That is, two of these
get together only
upon ligand binding.
They move together once
there is a ligand bound.
And then what happens is that
the tyrosine kinase domains
phosphorylate each other.
And that's activation in the
case of receptor tyrosine
kinases.
So when the small protein
ligand is not around,
this is a singleton.
It doesn't work on itself.
Once this ligand binds,
interactions change.
You get a dimeric
structure where one kinase
can phosphorylate
what's called in trans
the other kinase domains.
So it's different
from the GPCRs.
It's got a different
kind of feel to it,
but it's still a dynamic
transient signal.
Let's take a look at
this within a cell
and see what kinds
of responses--
and this is in
response to EGF, which
is epidermal growth factor.
It's a cytokine that
promotes cell division.
So a lot happens with respect
to the action of a cell,
not to produce ATP,
but now to respond
by producing all the elements
that enable cells to grow
and proliferate.
So the epidermal
growth factor binds.
You get dimerization.
Upon that dimerization,
the kinase domain in one
structure-- in the blue one--
phosphorylates the
other, and vice versa.
They phosphorylate each
other intermolecularly.
Once that has happened, through
the auspices of another protein
I won't bother you
with the name of,
this phosphorylated
intracellular RTK
binds to a small G protein.
In this case, it's a
monomeric G protein,
not one of the trimeric ones,
a small one known as RAS.
Once that binding event
occurs, guess what?
RAS gets activated.
It's now binding
GTP instead of GDP.
And then it starts going
through a sequence of events
where there's a ton
of controlled cellular
phosphorylation
events that result
in moving a protein into
the nucleus that helps
form a transcription
complex that results
in cellular proliferation.
Similar but different
series of events.
There's still amplification.
There's still dynamics.
And in this case, it's a lot
of phosphorylation events.
And what I want
to sort of define
for you is that many
of these pathways
are in trouble in
disease states.
Be it inflammation,
neurodegeneration, or cancer,
there is aberrant behavior of
proteins within these pathways
that cause them to go wrong,
cause cells to proliferate out
of control or undergo
bad responses.
And that is why
these proteins end up
being therapeutic targets
like the G protein coupled
receptors.
OK, so we've seen the
characteristics of signaling.
We've seen a signal.
We've seen amplification.
We've seen responses.
What I just want
to quickly show you
is an idea about integration.
So here's an idea with
two signaling pathways
that sort of end up with the
same signal outside where you
integrate actions through
two different signaling
pathways to achieve a bigger,
different kind of response.
So that's that last hallmark
of signaling pathways.
It's not that every pathway
is clean and straight.
It has cross-talk
with other pathways
and you get amplified
or different responses.
Tremendously complicated.
I want to give
you one more term.
And then I'll show one table.
When these pathways
go wrong, it's often
because switches get stuck on.
So for example, a G protein gets
stuck in its GTP-bound state
or doesn't even need
GTP to be activated.
Or a tyrosine kinase
is stuck activated.
And that's what's called
constitutively active,
basically meaning
it's permanently on.
So many of the diseases
that are caused by mutations
in your genome, not
genetic diseases
but mutations in your genes
in some particular cells,
end up with
constitutive activation
where you don't need a
signal to have a response.
And so for example, cells may
proliferate out of control.
So that is an important
term to know and understand.
Because constitutive
activation basically
means that a receptor may
be active in the absence
of a ligand.
And I believe this
is my last slide.
I just wanted to
leave you with this.
When one thinks of
GPCRs, there are
tremendous therapeutic targets.
The world of kinases
is no less important.
This scale is in
billions of dollars
spent on developing molecules
that may be curative
of diseases that involve
dysregulated signaling.
And what you see on this, I
want to point out two things.
Of course this thing stops
working at the last minutes.
But what I want to point
out is this particular bar.
This represents the
billions of dollars
spent on protein
kinase inhibitors
over a five-year period.
And it's just escalating
and escalating.
Similarly, monoclonal
antibodies are very important.
But the small molecule
drugs hold a real dominance.
What do these drugs do?
They enable you to have
small molecules that
can go into dysregulated
signaling pathways
and stop the activity somewhere
in the pathway to avoid signals
going constantly to the
nucleus and turning things
on all the time.
So both of these types of
functions in cellular signaling
are ones you want
to understand both
from a biological perspective
but from a medical perspective.
OK--